uh you had a bunch of interactions with
Jaguars how are you still alive like
what man dude just Jax Jacks aren't the
Jags I'll tell you this Jags are not the
danger the falling trees are the danger
uh I'll tell you some elephant stories
and then you'll then you'll then you'll
wonder why I'm still alive but
um Jags I've I've just one you know so
JJ started and Santiago his dad started
challenging me to do solos
go out alone into the wild style
you know I'd have a hammock a headlamp
three days worth of food some fish hooks
a machete that's it and so like one of
the stories that that happened early on
was I was out there and it was raining
and I was lost and
this is how we test your jungle
knowledge can you survive out there do
you know how to find food Have you
listened to the things that we taught
you and there was one night that I was
in a hammock
and a Jaguar came up and I was asleep
when it happened and she came up right
next to my head and she was and I could
hear her smelling me
and then my first instinct was to to to
turn on my headlamp and just the sound
of my arm moving against the the
material and she just
like she just right here I could feel
her breath and I just laid there
in the dark and that's one of those
moments where you go you really learn a
lot about yourself
because I wasn't scared I I felt like I
understood the intentions of the cat if
she was hunting I'd already be dead she
was curious and I was lost and I didn't
know if I was ever going to get out of
that jungle but what she did was
energize me because it was an experience
like the giant anaconda where I said
this is so wild
that it's that it's so almost
cinematically outside the realm of what
I thought my life could be like
that it made me like wait
because the previous day I was lost
tired confused kind of devastated tail
between my legs after that
I was like man you've been waiting for
this your whole life
go get it and I like woke up and I was
like I am gonna navigate even though
I've been in this swamp for three days
I'm gonna find my way out of this swamp
and like she just like breathed fire
into me where it was like
it was like if that's possible if I
could be six inches away from a Jaguar's
face
then I got I got that energy from her so
that you're able to start to really hear
and feel the
the jungle around you yeah that was uh
that was a sign do you know what you're
doing it really felt like a sign I
really did